I remember a few years ago when when you
went to some through something you know
extremely tragic I I emailed you just
just to know of love and
support and you quoted that back to me
then in an email and I I was just blown
away by that because I have quoted pain
plus reflection equals progress by you a
million times I think I repeat that in
every keynote I give because I think
it's such a powerful
it's such a powerful principle because
as soon as you remove the word
reflection progress disappears and all
you're left with is pain and when you
repeated that back to me in that moment
I thought wow like to remember that
principle in this moment requires so
much just just so much depth and I was
truly Blown Away by that because that's
one thing writing it and it's another
thing living in the incident that you're
referring to is the worst thing that
could ever have happened to me whether
um I would rather die than have it
happen was the loss of my son
yeah but you know meditation helps a lot
right so meditation and reflection
because whenever there's pain there's a
reality it tells you something about
reality and it tells you something about
how to deal with reality the reflections
yeah where Life Is Life it comes at you
it is reality you can't change it okay
you can influence it based on your
reactions yeah but you have to deal with
it and you have to deal with it in a
calm way so meditation helps you be calm
it helps you see the clarity and then
move beyond that to deal with the
circumstances well I think